okay so black panther wakanda forever
has just had its first look release
online and throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking it down going over the
easter eggs in it and also the new
characters and what happens to them in
the comics this is probably my most
anticipated upcoming marvel movie and
unfortunately due to the death of
chadwick boseman it's had a very
difficult development period during his
battle with cancer chadwick kept it a
secret from almost everyone around him
and thus marvel didn't even know that he
had the disease going back and watching
his performances it's incredible that he
was even able to deliver to the level
that he did and it's a testament to how
strong of a person he was he obviously
left a big hole and this film will very
much center around the mantle being
passed due to controversies around
letitia wright there's been a lot of
different rumors over whether she's
gonna get it or not and from this first
look it seems like there might even be
multiple people fighting for it the
movie is also gonna be introducing
neymar riri williams and it will center
around the war between wakanda and
atlantis we're going to be breaking it
all down but if you could smash that
thumbs up button and also subscribe for
heavy spoilers forever without the way a
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the trailer
[Music]
okay so the trailer itself is extremely
somber and we open with a cover of bob
marley's no woman no cry molly sadly
passed away at the age of 36 and us
being robbed of an icon is something
that feels like it might be echoing the
death of chadwick boseman i hope i don't
sound disrespectful there but it's kind
of the emotion and reason behind why i
think this song was chosen really got me
teary-eyed and this is one of the most
beautiful trailers that i think i've
ever watched chadwick's imagery is laced
throughout the teaser and we also get
what i believe might even be the funeral
of t'challa how he dies we don't really
get to see but there's this strong focus
on him with him even getting his own
mural they of course did something
similar and far from home with tony
stark but here it feels infinitely more
impactful due to the real life knowledge
that we have about the actor the funeral
at points comes across as a celebration
with several large groups dancing but
sure he looks really sad and due to some
of the shots it seems like she's gonna
be taking the mantle from t'challa we
get imagery of what appears to be the
throne room flooded and this is also
ablaze which reminds me a lot of
killmonger's ascension in the first
movie and there are room is that she
will make an artificial purple herb and
this will be how she becomes the
character ashore in the comics had
wanted to become the black panther for
quite a while she actually even tried to
challenge the mantle of it only to
discover her brother had succeeded in
becoming the one but this definitely
remained one of her goals
she became a fierce warrior and claimed
her first kill by defeating radioactive
man with the ebony blade this led to her
older brother seeing the potential in
here and slowly he started to train her
after the events of dark rain due to an
assassination attempt by doctor doom
t'challa was left in a coma in this time
shuri became an acting ruler and thus
this entitled her to use the
heart-shaped herb however the panther
goddess did not imbue her with the
powers due to a life of jealousy of her
brother and also her attitudes towards
the gods she did however gain the powers
eventually after proving herself when
fighting against the super villain
maulin ashiri actually died during the
time runs out storyline when defending
wakanda from the cabal time runs out is
sort of a prerequisite to secret wars
and with us heading in that direction he
could hint towards where the character
is going however with the passing of
chadwick boseman i think they'll change
things around and instead keep the focus
on her rather than going that route now
we can see nakia standing on a beach
shore and in the background you can make
out either aztec or mayan temples
beaches appear at several points
throughout and it of course hints at the
surface meeting the ocean much like what
this movie will be about the film is
changing up neymar's origin slightly and
judging by this new look i think it
works really well whereas dc gave us a
technologically advanced atlantis here
it seems more traditional and we get
several shots of him throughout this
includes what i'm guessing is the
character's birth and we can see that he
has fins on his feet in the comics they
kind of went back and forth between this
being finns and wings but it's nice that
they're at least sticking with that as
it's a big part of his design now it's a
bit ironic that he's only getting
introduced in the mcu as he's actually
one of the longest standing characters
in the marvel universe he debuted as a
character way back in 1939 before marvel
had even been founded this was in motion
pictures funny weekly volume one issue
one which if you don't own you're not a
real fan you're not a real fan
now there are actually some elements in
his origin story that are meant to be
happening in the film the source
material centered around a character
called ernest shackleton who had been
sent out to get vibranium by winston
churchill this is where he came across
neymar aka the king of atlantis aka the
first mutant now according to a report
by daniel rpk lake bell's character will
have been given a similar mission and
this is when she and her group will
awaken neymar who's lying beneath the
ocean in stewards is of course also
happened in avengers end game with akoye
bringing up an underwater earthquake
that had many old theory time about how
this was a hint to neymar now in the
comics he joined the invaders during
world war ii after nazi divers were
discovered near atlantis fighting
alongside captain america and the
android human torch they won the war but
in atlantis he was exiled now later on
in the comics he became a fellow the
fantastic four in part due to atlantis
being destroyed in nuclear tests however
that didn't stop him simply for sue
storm who i hear in the a38 is now a
single mother
[Applause]
anyway after a fight with the avengers
he found people worshiping a dude in ice
and he threw this like it was some chump
as i'm sure you can guess though this
contains steve rogers who'd fought
alongside him during the second world
war neymar is super powerful and also a
mutant which he actually found out after
being told by charles xavier though he's
going to be a villain in this he's very
much an anti-hero in the comics that
constantly swaps sides he was even in
the illuminati at one point or as
they're known in the 838 the suicide
squad
anymore and atlantis have had many
face-offs against wakanda and during the
events of avengers vs x-men he went to
free a mutant prisoner trapped in the
african city he launched a massive
attack and swamped them using a gigantic
tidal wave tempers died down after the
event but this atrocity was not
forgotten by t'challa and eventually war
was declared on atlantis not neymar
completely hated wakanda and at one
point in the comics he even lied to
thanos and said an infinity stone was
there just so he would attack it this
was obviously used in infinity war but
it's going to be interesting to see how
other elements are brought across now at
one point in the trailer we see him in a
full headdress the skull of which looks
like it belongs to a giant sea serpent
seems later on that neymar looks over a
mural of this so potentially it could be
linked to how him or his lineage gained
the crown there's also two whales with
atlanteans adorned on top of them later
on we also see that the throne is the
jaws of either a great white or possibly
even a megalodon just depends on how
short neymar is
he might be two foot or something now we
see the atlanteans at several points and
unlike neymar it seems like the majority
of them have blue skin this pulls
directly from the comics and most of the
atlanteans were blue which is why he
stood out so much looks like they also
need masks when on the surface whereas
we see neymar doesn't this is laced
throughout the trailer something that
pulls from the comics and they might
explain it as him being a highborn so he
can breathe oxygen in the comics he had
a mixed lineage which explained these
changeups and they're clearly bringing
it across to this movie
there's a lot of shots of characters
backs and this gives us an almost pov
perspective of them as we follow the
characters walking through the trailer
at one point he and his forces arrive at
what seems to be wakanda and they end up
facing off against him baku now the
trailer is big and bombastic and surely
you can't be serious if you think
several people won't be vying for the
crown shirey will likely take up the
mantle but i kinda hope that umbaku does
too he was definitely a standout in the
first film and he of course fought
heavily during infinity war i think with
chadwick's passing as well it's
difficult to find anyone who can take
over it without someone somewhere
complaining about it like it's the
she-hulk cgi so therefore like it's
pretty bad to be fair and therefore they
could make it a shared title
unfortunately daniel kaluya won't be
featuring in the movie judah's
scheduling conflicts which sucks as i'd
have loved to have seen him in the film
especially with how much he's done since
the original released now on to some
personal news the woke mob and cancel
culture finally got my family my uncle
has struggled to sell any ice cream
since he launched his infinity cones
shop it's a damn disgrace and if you
love free speech then what i'm going to
need you to do is show your support by
also subscribing to our clips channel
which is linked on the top comment it's
not a grift i swear it's all going to
support in infinity cones
it also seems like we get them sending a
tidal wave in and we get some awesome
action scenes on top of this obviously
people from the surface fighting people
from the ocean is a big juxtaposition
got got that word in there and it's
going to be interesting to see how they
balance it all out so also sorry for
ruining the emotional video with a crap
joke now lays throughout this is the
feeling that the kingdom itself is down
on its luck raimonda has stepped up as
queen in the wake of the death of her
husband and son and clearly she's lost a
lot which leads to a very powerful scene
i am queen of the most powerful nation
in the world and my entire family
is gone
have i not given everything
she also visits the un which is of
course how the last movie ended you see
those around here are wearing masks
mirroring the atlantean ones i think
these likely have symbolic meaning
though and they also put their mics down
too whilst terra remains up maybe in
their grief they've taken a vow of
silence but it's difficult to fully
guess what's going on with just a two
second shot i'm guessing this had to do
with a pandemic as they filmed
throughout that and maybe they've
incorporated it somehow into the story
itself amongst the trailer we also get
what i'm guessing is the expedition to
unearth either atlantis or the vibranium
there's also what appears to be a
mercenary outfit attacking wakundens at
one point it looks like a distress call
might be put out which judging by this
merck's face he's very shocked by also
again they're wearing masks which is
likely due to the pandemic but it's nice
to see that they've kind of incorporated
this into the costume design and
possibly the story or i'm reaching and
they were always going to have this now
on top of this i'm going to throw
another guess your way but i think this
might be used to show shuri's saving
them but hey let me know your thoughts
below seems later on they get saved by
the dora melange but i'd love to see
shuri introduced as the black panther
here too now at this point we also see
shuri meeting riri williams riri
williams aka iron heart first appeared
in invincible iron man vol 3 issue 7.
she was a super genius and gained an
early admission to mit now though she
had a bright childhood she ended up
experiencing a lot of tragedy when her
best friend and stepfather was shot in a
drive by in chicago this kind of put her
on a path to build her own suit of armor
and she cobbled one together using
outdated iron man parts and stolen
things from mit obviously mit they don't
want people just stealing stuff and it
led to security trying to confront her
only for her to escape in a model 1 suit
similar to tony's mark 1. the movie does
seem to be changing this up quite a bit
as it appears like she's using parts of
a car we can also see that she has a
diamond-like arc reactor that tony used
in end game so potentially she ended up
getting this from the compound or after
he handed it over the cap also make sure
everyone knows i spotted that
i mean mt from new rock stars he spotted
it first but
i i i was thinking about it at the same
time that tony did take an interest to
her and her armor building hobby and he
later recruited her to help fight
against captain marvel during civil war
ii also side note mt did spot that on
twitter and i told him i'd steal it so
it's all it's all fair it's as far as
i'm concerned now after tony fell into a
coma during the battle she decided to
continue his legacy and took the name
iron heart as iron heart she joined the
champions along with other mcu heroes
like ms marvel and took part in the
underground to fight against a double
gang of captain america in secret empire
she hammers out a heart and this imagery
of hammering something is of course
riffing on tony stark doing it in the
cave we then get bloody everett everett
bloody ross before ending on black
panther unleashing their claws again i'm
guessing this is shuri but it might not
be at the same time so don't kill me if
it's not now as for my thoughts on the
trailer i want to go through them before
i talk about a big leak on the movie and
what's being said about the character
who turns up at the end i'll make it
obvious before we get into that though
so you don't find out it was agatha all
along wait cut that cut
anyway this was a real blast to watch
and at this point i don't know to me the
movie kind of feels like it's an
underdog but also that it's going to be
massive obviously the first one was a
major success but the sequel has had so
many setbacks that i really wanted to do
well and it looks great too they've got
this really strong emotional vibe going
on with it i think it's not only gonna
honor chadwick but also build upon his
legacy to cement it really really blown
away by this first look feels like one
of the best trailers i've ever seen and
i don't know if i'm overly emotional or
what but yeah hype levels are at an
all-time high now as for the leaks in
the film this comes courtesy of daniel
rpk who talked about several of the
major plot points in the movie however
the one i want to go over is the ending
and who's revealed to be behind
everything if you don't want to know
that because it's quite a big spoiler
and check out now but if you do and i
want to tell you you're in the right
place this is the heavy spoiler show
anyway according to daniel lake bell's
character will be revealed to have been
hired by none other than dr doom he will
apparently appear at the end of the
movie in a comic book acura costume
before we cut to black now take this all
with a grain of salt and obviously what
he wants with atlantis we don't know yet
but with a fantastic four also coming
soon it seems to make sense that this is
gonna tie directly into secret wars in
the comics after the multiverse cracked
open he became an emperor of the
fractured timelines and though they
could also be doing that with kang i
think doom fits the comics more anyway
that's the main leak circulating around
about the film take it with a pinch of
salt sometimes the leaks are right
sometimes the leaks are wrong i'm not
promising you this here
but in the meantime i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the trailer and also
the whole h panel as well it's about 2
am in the morning in england as well so
any thumbs up it's much appreciated now
as a thank you for doing that you'll be
entered into a competition where we're
giving away doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video like
i said make sure you subscribe and also
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the teaser you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
if that is you message me on twitter
heavy spoilers now now if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our video on screen right
now that goes over how to beat
homelander he's a damn son of a [ __ ]
but i'm gonna tell you how to do it you
better go over there right after this
i'll see you soon punk you damn chump
see ya chump